hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the Grantchester again it's 11
Origen vs. Magnus Carlsen so in the
first game Magnus took the lead by
winning the game and that means six
points for him as a win in the classical
time format is counted for six and now
eleven should really really equalize and
or otherwise it's gonna be really hard
to get back into the match I will just
repeat it a few more times because I win
in the rapid time format is four points
and the win in the blitz is only two
points so as he already lost one game in
the class what he should really win one
game in the classical that being said do
be a part of the subscribers video 2020
all the information you need about that
will be in the description below which
I'm sure you already know but just in
case so without further ado let's check
out a nice photo before the match here
it is
this young girl does the first move for
11 and this time it's d4 and eleven
leaves it on the board it's hard to say
if Levin was actually planning to play
d4 or he just didn't want to yeah you
know I'm play another move but I'm
pretty sure yeah he was gonna play d4 so
that being said let's check out the game
d 4 by 11 and nice to have six by Magnus
we have c4 g6 and now f3 we have night
nice to see six by Magnus inviting d5 11
goes for it we have d5 in the not Knight
to e5 and now e for so the Kings Indian
defense we have d6 and now Knight to c3
by 11 we have Bishop to g7 and now going
even further with the pawn with f4
pushing the knight back and now Bishop
to e3 so this has all been played before
nothing new here we have castles by
Magnus and Bishop to e2 with e6
challenging 11th strong center with D
cap Tristan e6f captures and e6 and now
there is one game from the Russian
championship from this year pharisee
versus a sorry TR Pishko pharisee vs.
trapiche where a Knights the h3 was
played and Pharaoh save was able to win
that game but here we have h 4 by 11
which is a new movie
the position so already as of 11:00 we
have a completely new game so let's see
how Carlson deals with this he goes for
b5 which probably weren't one of the
moves that he had studied studied at
home it's it looks like a too powerful
of a move to make over the board but
okay it's basically giving up upon you
don't want to give a white time to
consolidate the white king is still in
the center so you want to start
developing pieces as soon as possible so
just giving up a pawn for the moment and
you have to capture with the point as
the knight is stuck covering the e4 pawn
so we have C capture son b5 and now
Bishop the b7 putting pressure on the e4
pawn we have Queen to b3 now Levin says
okay I'm gonna capture on e6 with check
so now even if you even if you try
something like knife captures here it's
not gonna work because after all the
trades I'm just gonna deliver check and
pick up your piece on e4
so here while Magnus could go for Queen
to e7 now he prefers King to h8 he
invites 11 to capture a nice it but it
wouldn't be all that great it's it's
interesting but after Queen captures an
e6 and the Knight captures on e4 now
again it doesn't work Knight chapters
here and now rook to e8 now white is the
one that gets troubled with a piece
hanging on e4 so after the Queen moves
you're just gonna capture the night or
you can go for this Knights the g5 idea
which is now Queen captures rook
captures on e6 Knight f7 check Forks the
king and the Queen and after the King
moves and now you capture and the rook
captures here where you get this
position where white would be up a pawn
but it's a double beep on and well your
your Bishop is hanging on e3 or ponies
hanging and g2 black would definitely be
better here so instead after this King
take shade moved by Magnus and Bishop to
f3 first adding another defender to the
pawn here and now Magnus just gets rid
of the weak bones by pushing the pushing
it's the e6 d5 with Knight to h3 by 11
defending on f4 and now Knight to h5 by
Magnus adding another attacker to the f4
square also the knight can jump to g3 if
needed and here 11 makes a very concrete
decision he decides to capture on h5
we
gee captors and now push the pond all
the way to f5 and now if Magnus will
will be unable to push d5 then this
white structure should be should be
excellent and also the pond on h4 that
seems to be hanging if Magnus goes for
it he would actually be in a pretty bad
position because after night f2 you
defend check you also guard the rook and
once the Queen moves you will pick up
the h5 point the Queen has no squares
from where the Queen can defend the pawn
so you're just gonna have to go back
Queen d7 now you pick up the pawn here
and now well with the Queen slicing old
all the way to g8 the rook attacking h7
you can Castle queenside you can bring
the other look over to h1 it would just
be a too good of a position for white so
after this f5 move by 11 we have Knight
to f6 by Magnus and now Knight to f
night the f2 also Knight to g5 you could
try that but you're not coming to e6
anytime soon since after Queen t7 now it
would be it would be pointless because
the e4 pawn is hanging so it is possible
but it requires a much more deciding
than what Levin invested so lemon has a
different plan Knight to have to just
add another defender to the pawn here
and now a 6 Magnus wants to give up the
a6 bonus well further activate his
pieces with b6 Levin says we're not
going to free your roof just like that
so we have pawn capture special
characters with an attack on the Queen
and now Queen to d7
we have rook to d1 again 11 keeps keeps
an eye on the d5 square he does not want
to let Magnus play d5 we have rook a to
c8 and now comes in Bishop back to e3 by
11 and now h6 just making some room room
for the King on h7 we have rook the h3
our very nice rook lifted by 11 now the
rook can come to g3 put pressure on the
position you can also bring the rook to
g6 to put pressure on the h6 pawn you
can go to f3 if you'll need it to defend
the f5 pawn a lot of good ideas here for
the rook and it's better than just a
castle since you can always play some
like king f1 king g1 and the king will
be very safe there so here
Magnus takes this up
now is the queen is nicely placed on the
seven attacking the f5 point to push d5
and now already you have a threat of d4
which would just win material sullivan
has to capture with it captures on d5
and now yes the queen is attacking the
f5 pawn but also the white queen is
attacking the b7 bishop so first the
ship back to be better back to a8 now
capturing is definitely a threat rook
the f3 by 11 defending it and now rook
to b8 also by playing Bishop they pay a
8 you free the B file for the rook Queen
back to c2 and now rook F to c8 so
activating both both the rooks for the
temporary pawn sacrifice or maybe not a
temporary one sacrifice we'll see how it
goes we have Queen to e2 by 11 and
pinning and also preparing to move the
rook and go after the h5 pawn but we
have Queen to f7 adding another defender
to the h5 pawn we have Queen to d2 now
attacking the h6 pawn but Magnus just
defense King to h7 but now everything is
perfectly set and 11 goes the night
after efore and now he's threatening
just 96 to win material so Carlsen
trades once Knight captures captures and
the now rook to d8 guarding the d6
square but now xi can finally push f6
opening up this very important diagonal
towards the towards the black King
Bishop to f8 and now Queen to c2
threatening some very nasty discoveries
like Knight to g5 check picking up the
Queen for example as it would be a
double check so King to h8 Magnus on
pins and now Knight back to c3
consolidating putting another defender
to the d5 pawn and now 11 will have to
choose between some very good options on
how to continue the game and the Magnus
has to do the same here Magnus could go
for captures on d5 it's it is a
possibility but he would have to trade
down into an unfavorable position for
example in rush of captures rook
captures rook captures Knight captures
with Queen captures on d5 and now b3 and
you get a disposition but it would just
be very hard to play for example if rook
d8 not allowing the Queen to leave the
defense of the d1 square
King it
and now after efore attacking the rook
rook at four
you put pressure on the pawn here and
here Blackwood for example trade Queens
captures captures you will go king d2
and now it's just a better position for
white since well these two pawns are
weak you can very easily win this pawn
so it's just just a better position for
whitey if not winning
so here Magnus doesn't go for it his
best chances is his best chance to
survive this game is to just complicate
the position as much as possible so he
goes rogue before with ideas of rook
captures and h4 rook h1 check maybe a
stirring some trouble there xi just
defends it Quint f2 and now Bishop
captures on d5 now Bishop captures on d5
is a bit different because the black
queen is at the white queen is not on
such an active square so here if you
trade it captures captures captures and
captures you would get to this position
where it's black who is very much active
and white white not so much White is
still better but xi doesn't like like
that he can push for more here so
instead after Bishop captures and b5 not
the rook is under attack
you still can't capture the rook because
the rook on d8 would be hanging but
still best for lemon is just rook to f5
here put some pressure on that h5 pawn
maybe you can attack it with the Queen
next and just start mounting the
pressure and get the rook away from the
f3 square but here xi saw the
opportunity for for a very nice idea and
he played Bishop to c5 Bishop to c5 and
gives the Magnus a chance to wiggle out
of a terrible position so feel free to
pause the video and try to find why a
what Magnus played successfully wiggle
out of this position while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
on finding such such a nice idea it's
not an easy move to find you have to you
know combine a few of the ideas that
we've already mentioned
so basically Levin's idea is after
Bishop to c5 that well if Bishop
captures your Luke is under attack so
that's that's the first thing there is
so after Bishop captures Queen captures
now your roof will be under attack and
also there will be a triple attack on
the bishop here so your only option to
defend against both is rook to d4 to
somehow permit both threats but it
doesn't really work because rook
captures pawn captures and the now
Justin Knight captures on d5 rook
captures on d5 and now okay it's queen
and rook against the Queen and rook but
you have Queen to c8 check King to h7
and now rogue g3 and white wins the game
there is no defense against rook to g7
which will win the Queen and of course
if you eliminate the f6 bond then Queen
g8 is just made so that was a Levin's
plan when he played Bishop to c5 but he
missed the move Magnus played and
congratulations to everyone who found it
which is rook to d4 roof to d4 is an
awesome move because now Magnus is
saying okay your rook on d1 is under
attack I'm threatening just rook
captures check and then I'm gonna pick
up your rook here because now Bishop
captures an f3 is a threat because you
cannot go through both rooks to pick up
material on d8 so here 11 really doesn't
have a better move other than capturing
the room which is what he does he plays
Bishop captures on d4 we have Bishop
captures on f3 by Magnus G captures and
then now he captures on d4 we have rook
captures on d4 and now everything is
nicely traded now Magnus could capture
on f6 and keep an eye on the rook here
but he decided that better chances are
rook to b8 just leaving that f6 bone
where it is but he misses a very very
nice move by 11 which is Queen to h2 he
moves the Queen on pins and prepares to
centralize the Queen and now any Queen
captures on f6 by attacking the
recurring possible because the rook on
b8 is hanging so here look the b6 but
now 11 gets the knight into the game
Knight to d5 attacks the rook while the
f6 point is defended and now he keeps
his very strong past f6 pawn we have
Quinta ecigs by Magnus with Czech Queen
e2 left 11 offers the Queen trade and
the Magnus declines it and it's he
declines it with with a very wet a
beautiful resource Queen to g8 he offers
the rook on d6 and because now if you
captured the rook he has Queen g1 check
which
connects with the rook but also with the
night and here xi would have to accept a
draw with queen f1 and Queen III check
now you cannot move the King anywhere
sorry not that but you can go king that
he won because rook Falls with check and
then you also pick up the night so then
Coulson would be just winning so here
you would X you would have to accept a
draw by threefold repetition after a
series of checks so after Queen 2g 8:11
sees that the rook is off-limits he was
king to f1 but now rook to e6 Magnus now
attacks the Queen and here both of them
were very low on time and xi didn't just
move the Queen for example Queen to h2
is a is a reasonable move but xi found
an even nicer move he played f7 which is
kind of weird as it gives up a very
strong test f6 pawn but little Evan
finds a very nice combination Queen
captures on f7 and now rook to f4 so
this is just a beautiful move because
now the rook is under attack
the Queen is under attack and if the
Queen moves then you are no longer
guarding the rook but if you move too
far away from the defense of the bishop
then the bishop is also under attack so
here at the point point of opponent
point of everything is that if Magnus
goes for the Queen's red rook captures
rook captures then your rook is under
attack and also your Bishop is under
attack so if you go rook to e8 to defend
both now Knight to f6 wins 411 because
the rook is under attack and also rook
to h7 is the threat of mate so it cannot
to defend against in both threats so
after rook to f4 now Magnus finds again
a brilliant move Queen to g6 he gives up
the bishop on f8 with check we have rook
captures on f8 and now King to g7
now the Queen is under attack Queen has
to move we have pointed e1
defending the knight and now King
captures on f8 so for the moment Magnus
is of the exchange but only for the
moment Knight to f4 attacks the Queen
and the rook we have Quinta yet and now
Knight captures rook we have Queen
captures on e6
and now Queen to d8 check and we enter
this endgame where xi is up upon but
it's a queen and ponent game and we
already saw how difficult Queen opponent
games are in the same championship
the same Grantchester finals between
ding and nvl so keen to f7 we have Queen
to c7 check King to yet and now Queen to
be a twit check we have King the d7 by
Magnus and Quinta b7 check King to d8
Magnus is very very happy with the draw
here this is the last classical game
he's most likely the last class game
she's playing in that in 2019 and so far
he hasn't lost a single game in 2019 so
he would very much enjoy not losing this
game
so Queen be it check King the 7 we have
Queen to e7 check and King back - he ate
with b3 now 11 gives Magnus a move but
now Queen to h3 with check now Magnus
will pick up the h4 pawn we have think
that e 2 and twin captors on h4 with
this Magnus created the past H born we
have we not going F for a 611 waits for
that he first wants to push a 4 a 5 a 4
and B 4 so the point will get a bit
closer so Queen to be a check first King
e7 and now Queen the c7 with check King
to f8 now he has to play it moves
quickly because both of them are very
low on time Queen c5 check King g7 and
now Queen to e5 with check King to g8
and now a 4
now we have Quinta H 1 and now Queen to
be a twitch f king of 7 and now Queen to
f4 with check King to 8 we have Quinta
b8 with check in the now King to d7
Quinta a7 with check King to d8 and now
Quinta d4 with check King Teti 8 and now
Queen to e5 with check so play moves
hoping that to get an idea without
wasting too much time King the seven
Queens the d4 with check came to it and
now before now Magnus gets a move Queen
G to check we have Queen to f2 offering
a trade of course you cannot afford a
Queen trade Queen to g5 and now f4 we
have Queen to d5 and a now Queen III
check King to f7 and now Queen to e7
width check King to e8 you don't want to
go to the 6th rank so you don't lose the
a6 pawn with check
and now Queen to c5 again offering a
queen trade and if the Queen moves you
can pick up the h5 point but Queen the a
to check now Magnus connected this with
the a4 pawn King to f3 and now Queen
captures on a4 Queen captures on h5 and
now it's a queen upon endgame with two
points each now this is a this is a dead
draw King e7 was played Queen e5 check
came to f7 and now Queen d5 check King
g7 Queen d4 check King to f7 and Queen
b5 check King g7 Queen d4 check and
after king f7 the players agree to a
draw here or basically it's a it's a
three-fold repetition maybe either
either either of those but I'm sure they
would agree to a draw even even if it is
a draw by a threefold repetition so
really insane stuff eleven really played
beautifully he almost had him almost
ruined and Carson's a good year by you
know by beating him to last the game he
had prior to this game he had and 106
games unbeaten streak and with this game
he's now on it on a 107 games unbeaten
streak and it's it's it's bad luck for
lemon because now he has to go into
rapid games being down six points as he
was the first game to Magnus but you
know he still has chances though there
are two more rapidly and for more boots
games so anything can happen yeah that's
basically the game I do hope you enjoyed
it or really well we'll see what happens
if you've been if you've been watching
the the live coverage for example on
just 24 hour with Peter Svidler spoiler
often often says that 1111 skills in
blitz are gone like so now we're gonna
definitely gonna see what happens there
as it's just anything can happen but
yeah Magnus definitely now the huge
favorite and he ends the year by being
undefeated which is which is awesome
stuff
last time he lost last time he lost was
in 2018 in July I'm sure you all know
who he lost to now we already discussed
that a few times but just in case you
don't feel free to check out the
comments below because I'm sure a lot of
people will mention it so that's the
game
- hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Braxton Reynolds and wanwan
Gentile virus for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
in my previous videos Aaron thank you
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
Grantchester finals checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and starting the
next big saga so say thank you all I
will see soon and have an excellent rest
of your Sunday and do be a part of the
subscribers video 2020 see you soon